une dominante rose sur des airs de hip
hop voilà les ingrédients de cette
manifestation organisée au gymnase des
baissière à maurepas danser en faveur de
la lutte contre le cancer du sein
c'était l'objectif de l'association
delight
c'est aux membres de l'association en
fait qui a été touché par cette maladie
da qui voulait elle mener ce combat là
et du coup ben on s'est dit bon on va la
suivre et puis on va la soutenir dans ce
combat pendant une heure et demie une
quarantaine de participants enchaîner
les mouvements lents et rapides
le court était ouvert à tous une manière
de montrer que tout le monde peut être
touché un jour par cette maladie est une
très bonne idée c'est bien il faut avoir
été soigné pour un cancer donc c'est
très bien dans ma famille un jeune ne
veut que un problème avec son cerveau
avec les gens de cochonneries donc mal
placé l'un placé pour vraiment un cours
de hip hop pour une bonne action puisque
l'ensemble des fonds récoltés sera
reversée à la ligue contre le cancer
[Applaudissements]